[Music]
are you ready to face bum if there's one
thing we've learned from watching
cartoons is that you should never ever
question cartoon logic from dogs walking
dogs to characters doing
rock-paper-scissors without actual hands
the cartoon logic sometimes just doesn't
add up stick around to see the biggest
relationship flaw in Spongebob
Squarepants don't forget to subscribe to
our Channel and comment how many times
you facepalms it during this video now
let's discuss some of the most
ridiculous examples of carts new logic
Arthur let's start with arguably one of
the best cartoons of the 90s Arthur is
based on the popular book by Mark Brown
the show follows the life of the
eight-year-old Arthur who's an aardvark
that basically looks like a human other
characters on the show are also animals
with plenty of human characteristics
while Arthur is definitely one of the
most fun 90s shows ever
it comes with tons of examples of
questionable cartoon logic animals
dressed as humans is definitely one of
them but if Yuri watch the show as an
adult you'll start questioning just
about everything that happens on the
show like this scene for example it
happens in the 17th season of the show
and it features an experimental band
called bang on a can all-stars in the
scene where the characters talk about
how awesome the band is you can see
Arthur listening to the music with his
headphone but check out how he's wearing
the headphones the speakers are placed
on both sides of his head just like as
if he was human but the trick is
Arthur's ears are actually placed way
higher shouldn't those headphones be
placed differently
he wouldn't be able to hear the music
this way or perhaps cartoon aardvarks
have more than just one pair of ears
they definitely didn't think this one
through Scooby Doo Scooby dooby doo
where are you
we've got some work to do now he doesn't
remember the incredible and sometimes
downright scary Adventures of scooby-doo
and his friends the show which first
aired in 1969 was so popular it even
featured two full-length movies starring
Sarah Michelle Gellar and Freddie Prinze
jr. as Daphne and Fred but before I made
it on our big screens the characters in
the show had to defeat plenty of
monsters and others sketch people who
were never up to any good here's where
cartoon logic fails you think that after
unmasking hundreds of people Shaggy and
Scooby would actually get used to the
fact that these monsters probably aren't
real monsters anyways right well not in
this show you could watch a thousand
episodes and Shaggy and Scooby would be
just as scared of the monsters as they
were the first time around another funny
example of the scooby doo logic is the
scene where scooby grab the lids of two
trash cans and started flying around
seems logical rights and let's not
forget about all the time Scooby entered
an abandoned house and automatically
searched for the fridge and then there
are of course the villains who seem to
get arrested just for scaring people
instead of committing an actual crime
regardless of all these facts you have
to admit that you loved scooby-doo as a
kid phineas and ferb cartoon characters
come in all shapes and sizes even though
some of them don't really make sense
from animals with weird characteristics
to regular humans with questionable
facial features you can still find some
odd things about how they look Finny
and ferb definitely has the most
interesting characters we've ever seen
but there's one thing that bugs us about
this show phineas has one of the oddest
shaped heads we've ever seen in a
cartoon character we really want to know
how he can fit into his clothing in the
first place if you look at his neck
you'll notice it's abnormally tiny when
compared to the rest of his head is this
why he seems to be wearing the same
clothes in every episode think about
what will happen when he grows older we
can imagine the clothes would magically
grow with him just so he doesn't have to
go through the process of putting on a
different outfit Ferb's outfit also
raises a few eyebrows as it seems like
it takes a long time to bring a shirt
down from the top of his head have you
seen Phineas his front face it makes his
triangle head completely disappear but
seriously we really want to know how
does Phineas managed to fit his clothes
through his head without stretching the
material Donald Duck wardrobe
malfunction seems to be a common theme
when it comes to questioning the logic
of cartoon characters some of the older
Disney characters take this to a
brand-new level Donald Duck first
appears back in 1934 and went through
several storylines but the actual
character remained the same throughout
did you know his middle name is
Fauntleroy as one of the most
recognizable Disney characters Donald
Duck has always been popular we usually
see him wear a sailor shirt a cap and a
red or black bowtie over the years this
hasn't really changed his image but
that's not what's going to make you
facepalm have you noticed anything
strange about Donald Duck like for
example how he never seems to wear pants
or any form of clothing that would cover
up his lower part of the body and yet
Donald Duck gets embarrassed when all of
his clothes get removed
he'll also cover his bottom part of the
body with a towel when he comes out of
the bath but then you'll see him run
around without any pants for the rest of
the day we've seen disney logic do
whatever they want when it comes to the
behavior of their characters but how can
you explain this one he
clearly acknowledges he's not wearing
any clothes whenever it's convenient for
him but he gets embarrassed when he
loses all of his clothes
spongebob squarepants and the winner of
failed cartoon logic examples goes to
SpongeBob SquarePants where do we even
begin how about the fact that these
characters live underwater and they're
still able to make a fire and that they
can have swimming pools and other forms
of water how they're already underwater
or the fact that a sponge is actually
washing dishes with a sponge when it
comes to wacky cartoons spongebob
squarepants has to be one of the most
ridiculous shows we've ever seen let's
not forget Sponge Bob tried to blow a
bubble while he was in a bubble himself
we've also seen spongebob lift a car
which struggled lifting but let's have a
look at probably one of the weirdest
relationships ever mr. Krabs is clearly
a crab right so how come his daughter is
a whale who is pearls actual mother she
never gets revealed but of course fans
of the show have come up with many
theories are you ready to have your
childhood ruined by the answer to this
cartoon logic
some fans assume that mr. Krabs isn't
pearls actual dad he's her sugar daddy
she only uses him to spend his money and
well do other things in return that we
would never ever talk about from physics
to relationships you have to admit that
the logic of Spongebob Squarepants made
you facepalm more times than you can
count
that's it for five ridiculous examples
of cartoon logic that will make you
facepalm for more videos like this one
check out ten cartoon secrets finally
revealed see you next time
[Music]